foreign
which was has been considered one of the
Premier Medical journals although as we
said at the top of the hour and as we've
said here before it has sort of long
since been understood including by many
doctors to not really be all that
serious after all
but they confirmed that if you will this
is this month December 2022 when they
published this study
and I'm just going to read some bits
from it um but don't don't put up my
screen just yet actually
um
I actually feel like I should give a
trigger warning before talking about
this because uh if there's there's sex
and types of sex and types of sexual
intercourse discussed in this article
which I think weren't just we're not
going to spend a lot of time here but uh
in order to understand what this paper
has done what the authors of this paper
have done and what this journal has done
by letting them publish it in this form
you need to go into some things that
some people will consider grotesque so
uh there there you go turn off now if
you're not interested in uh learning
about some of the differences between
how women and trans women actually
engage in sexual activity so uh here we
go you can put on my screen here Zach
this again published this in December
2022 by the Lancet human monkey pox
virus infection in women and
non-barinary individuals during the 2022
outbreaks a global case series
now you might think if you just look at
the headline that it's going to be about
women and non-binary individuals that's
the problem well no I will say here as
I've said many times non-binary isn't a
thing that's not a real category but
just stop it already you're just making
that up the non-binary individuals the
handful I think it was literally maybe
five
um
uh that they included here were all
um female actually not a sign female at
Birth but actually female observed
female
and the problem arises with their
category of women in which about half of
the women uh that are included in the
study aren't women of trans women who
are not women
so we are they're looking at Monkey box
which
for those of you who've been living
under some rock that wasn't infected by
monkey pox uh of course is mostly uh
mostly Ben an infection uh that gay men
get from gay sex that has mostly been
the case and so okay well yeah we should
see what's going on with women for sure
but maybe don't include a whole bunch of
men and call them women and thus further
confuse the issue so here are just a few
um sorry it's gonna It's Gonna Wanna pop
up um
non-sexual routes of transmission
including household and occupational
exposures were reported only in CIS
women and non-binary individuals so that
is to say that once again it's um the
it's all of the men included in the
study on women are actually being
exposed through sexual routes wait wait
wait wait wait this is actually it's not
an important because I'm not sure why I
highlighted that one
um in trans women this is research and
context this is sort of a you know if
you don't want to read the whole article
piece in trans women
oh wait sorry oh my God
I need to see the okay I'll just read
this in trans women commercial sex work
was reported in 34 and it's 55 of 62
individuals and was the strongest
occupational link to infection
24 is 34 of CIS women and non-binary
people women had vaginal mucosal
involvement and 59 of 71 had vulfur
lesions one trans woman had fallen for
involvement and no disease of the of the
vagina was described perhaps reflecting
sexual activity as few trans women had
undergone gender affirming surgery
I'm going to just keep going a little
bit here here it is HIV prevalence was
very high in trans women 50 percent
lower instas women and non-binary people
eight percent okay so the men that they
included in the study on women
were either half or more than half HIV
positive and sex workers
okay
point one
I and I'm sorry my screen does not want
to behave like
uh yeah I think it's I think it's
hanging up because I'm connected there
okay now you can show it again here
similarly large case series describing
the 2022 outbreaks of monkey pox virus
have included no or few women
and that continues to this day
and large epidemiological surveillance
data sets have not differentiated
between cisgender and transgender women
because
cisgender isn't a thing that's you're
either male or female and trans people
are real but the sex that they are
matters whereas the gender that they
think they are especially if they've had
no surgery in any way does not matter at
all with regard to Monkey box
okay a few more
would you like to respond yeah I would
like to respond before yeah okay okay
you can you can give me ice cream back
so I can get to the next one sec yes
is it
oh my God is it arrogant of me to think
that I'm not dumb uh yeah no it's not
arrogant for you to think you're not
done I don't think I'm dumb no I am
straining to understand this paper
because
it goes beyond jargon by pretending that
men who are trans women are something
other than men biologically it takes and
most of them are HIV positive and sex
workers right right right right yes but
I'm having trouble even getting there
because I'm struggling to keep track of
the fact that they've got women who are
men who are being lumped with other men
because they're men but the paper
doesn't say that they're all just men
because this isn't they've studied men
right
oh but they didn't they're not lumping
them with men here because they're no
men there's no there's no men in this
study
because they they are correcting
historical wrong here because monkey pox
because it mostly affects men who have
sex with other men
um have decided to look at women
right but except they didn't I mean they
did a few and then they found that among
the women who are mostly not sex workers
and not HIV HIV positive that there were
some cases of monkey pox but among the
men who think they're women
who were also mostly HIV positive and
sex workers uh that they were okay
there's just one more here
and this gets you know I didn't need to
know this but Zach if you want to show
my screen here
um the the type of sex that trans women
versus women and non-women which they're
calling Swiss women and non-binary
individuals the type of sex that they
have okay which includes anal oral and
anal oral only vaginal anal vaginal oral
vaginal only okay so these three types
and they've got them into various
categories
trans women
had no vaginal sex
because they're not women and they don't
have vaginas
they don't say that in the paper but
that's why but okay and women
says women and non-binary individuals
but women
no women had only anal sex only one of
them had only oral annual sex they
mostly had vaginal sex and mostly
they're not getting monkey pox
right so so you could take that off and
we're done with the grotesqueries here
now but it
I guess what I'm getting at here and I
mean I realize this is your point too
but I'm just struggling trying to
wrestle it into Clarity sure
this is a very obvious result yes
everything about the result oh yeah is
perfectly obvious this is a pattern
we've seen before right I mean this is
the pattern that we saw with AIDS right
we had
um gay men were getting AIDS anal sex
was a primary route of infection at
least in the west and therefore it
wasn't something about you know
the mindset of gay men it was about the
behavior of gay men which differed from
men who weren't gay
for obvious reasons bath houses and anal
sex turned out not to be good for you
right and it turns out if you're a woman
right and you were engaged in this
Behavior then the virus didn't care that
you weren't a gay man right so the point
is the result of the paper is perfectly
straightforward it's not really
newsworthy but the insane way that they
have categorized people obscures that
result so you have to you have to do
overtime like your social justice brain
has to unpack this result so that you
can show that you can properly read
through the idea of non-binary and uh
and CIS women I mean the whole idea that
you have to read this stupid code in
order to get a perfectly obvious result
of a pattern we've seen before right
this paper should be very easy to
understand and yet they have turned it
into a
um a monstrosity of needless complexity
by pretending that law all sorts of
things that have nothing to do with
Biology are fundamentally biological and
medical yeah no and let's uh let's
definitely look at uh monkey pox
Transmission in women
by doing a small study in which half the
people aren't women
right I you know like I don't
I I don't like sort of the rad fam move
to blame the patriarchy for a whole lot
of [ __ ] yeah like what what is going on
here but really
like what about studying women because
wasn't that the point right but no half
the people you they've not just because
they said they were an armadillo here
they're not an armadillo and they're not
women either like they're not and these
are
these are
trans women but
before they've had bottom surgeries that
the idea
okay so it's waning men
I'm sorry
oh yeah yeah thank you for not saying
hallelujah
appreciate that I
I mean some I know this is wrong but I'd
prefer it to be waxing men
um right and I don't like that image
either no that's uh
hairless at some level yeah yeah
[Music]